very last debate club what's up guys
Nathan from Chicago I'm half Vietnamese
so I need this debate question answered
cat is Vietnamese and Qin is Korean
which is better Vietnamese or Korean
food Gang Gang buzz-buzz I know the
answers let you guys answer them say
which people are better which food is
better region food always had food I
thought you said people two of my damn
dog first I bet they don't even know
Vietnamese cuisine no I can tell you a
dish you had no one for sure what's the
most popular well I hate fun that's not
a meal soups not a [ __ ] me but people
go you want to get fat nah dude I'm a
big spoon and I'm a grown man
I'm a can eat soup for a [ __ ] meal we
just said her size so it is a meal for
us
yeah I know imagine being a soul it just
being a semi not extremely hided kind of
human running around busy have to get
back to school quit yeah yeah and then
what's the what's what's the other dish
what would it would Korean food cream of
Korean barbecue come on I've only had
Korean barbecue once but I definitely
like it more than [ __ ] and you went to a
really bad place you know I like any
more than chin though what you know
something we went to or the worst
possible place watch our big yeah went
to Washington LA at least the place I
talked do keen sting needs to go man
yeah that'd be dope yeah we could do we
should do some Korean joint and he took
me to a bath house after they you know
we spa huh you were something I've been
to we spa a bunch no it was like this
hidden one I was like yeah he's like he
just pulled up and like you know stopped
his car and I was he was like we doing
this and I was like it's called a
chinchilla man I don't know it was like
you don't know it's there yeah and you
wear robes sometimes no they were not
gonna roll sometimes yeah I would do we
spot what guess found out it's like some
people can wear some trunks dude
everybody naked up in our then yeah
they're little dicks in your face we
don't eat it no we don't need it done he
was doing karate kicks in the sauna
I was like Bobby sit down
and he doesn't have a lot of muscles in
his body Bobby he's most heartless yeah
yeah he's cartilage and not even a lot
of bone you know you could fill his
whole leg and not find a bone in it he's
like Gumby you get that very unique body
type that kind of dots you ever seen
those stuff dots at the movies when you
get that tell me that futuristic
icecream oh yeah oh I love those yeah
he's got a lot of kind of like that's a
lot of bobbies I'm gonna go with Korean
foods better mm-hmm but I don't know
about Vietnamese and Korean would you
would one of you guys rather be the
other ethnicity no not me Wow very
prideful we should try some instead of
burgers see here's the thing though
Jessi my suit is very it's an acquired
taste not a lot of people are willing to
eat fish sauce even you're going Korean
food sounds like know I love Benetton I
love Vietnamese food I just know for
like if you're not Asian it's kind of
hard for you to eat how fans asked us to
try other food on this I haven't seen we
should do a spicy one I'll tell you this
story so I was at Shanghai mm-hmm and
that could be in one of you guys is my
Chinese and there we go and I also met a
man who was Taiwanese this weekend and
he said [ __ ] the Chinese told me yep
oh they hate the train I said look let
me get my globe out of the trunk
get into this but um I remember they had
a breakfast bar at this hotel and they
had one half was American and one half
was Chinese or Asian food and it was
strikingly different like I went on the
Asian side and it was just a total like
and it was breakfast and I'm like this
is breakfast there's a bunch of
different options oh they're like a
little like I don't even know some of it
was a lot of fish right out fish a lot
of like stuff that seemed like flakes a
lot of vegetables
a lot of like stuff you would see like
kind of by the beach a little bit
Chinese or bigger people though right
compared to Koreans and Koreans are
probably the biggest actual size people
yeah the biggest
I feel like Chinese
you can't even hide a Korean ramen
you're just thinking I mean just tell me
Jeremy anomaly
those are anomalies all right well
change the a giant Korean they're bigger
than me now
yummy not red like literally they found
the two tallest peak yeah he was already
fish recreated in the lab yeah um but
anyway so yeah I just think the food the
world the food world like you're saying
with fish sauce or whatever the food
worlds are totally very different you
know what they might like that is a the
bond me the barbecue one talk about the
actual barbecue delicious barbecue meat
by me yeah I think they would actually
dig that what ramens what Japanese we
should just bring stuff in and see what
you guys like better well you try to
bring them below remember yeah I've had
one of those before
it's like embryo you ate that bird yeah
yeah I had some threw up well also Jin
didn't cook it that was a mistake
I thought they were cooked already so
when they opened it was raw
bro that is okay sorcery is covered in
blood I didn't want to try it
you shoulda tried it you gotta get sick
dude I hit a couple hits of it man let's
see what else you got it's a unique I
would you know they don't have it at
Shoney's I'll say that I just put this
one up at the beginning of the episode a
bunch of [ __ ] marbles man it's just
such a tough women or too late look at
that Wow yeah that's 57% safe Korean
food that's interesting man yeah I think
I just think I don't have enough
experience with the two foods so I will
probably need to go to some restaurants
will bring it will bring something I
think they like curry I think you guys
would like Korean food more you never
know any excuse to wear those glasses
again yeah you can just eat dishes save
it yeah yeah yeah but we get which one
we like better than huh I'll tell you
what it is but but put in Chinese Korean
and
no Chinese soon no no no no Travis dude
from the mall it tastes like you have to
buy shoes in a few minutes I post mates
panda time I'll get a large entree only
orange chicken double you know you
shouldn't your pants and I Oh do double
the double scoop orange chicken you
talking about that sugar chicken dog I
feel so bad about myself after I do I
eat orange chicken I [ __ ] punch
myself I'm so disappointed myself dog
and that's in Keith Peterson says hey
man let's just go on a little walk
[Laughter]
[Music]
the king nice day
[Music]